Hallo zusammen, ich bin Sam von der Flugschule Free Wings und wir nehmen heute zusammen das Thema Flugpraxis durch.
Flugpraxis und wir sitzen hier in einem Studio drin, passt irgendwie nicht so ganz zusammen.
Was wir machen wollen, ist uns zuerst Wissen aneignen und das müssen wir oder können wir vor allem auch gut in der Theorie machen.
Weil wenn wir das Wissen haben, können wir rausgehen und trainieren und wenn wir das Trainieren gemacht haben, können wir mit dem Bereich des Können.
Und nur dieser Weg funktioniert. Das Wissen aneignen, trainieren und dann ins Können gehen.
Wenn du eines von diesen auslässt, kommt es meistens nicht so gut.
Darum konzertieren wir uns jetzt hier, uns das Wissen anzuneigen von der Flugpraxis.
Das Ziel von diesem Kurs ist schlussendlich eigentlich, dass ihr bei der Theoriebriefung, die der SAV durchführt,
die Thema Flugpraxis problemlos bestand.
Am besten natürlich mit 100 Punkten, respektive 100%.
Das ist am Ende die richtige Frage.
Für das Ganze ist es gut, wenn man, wie die Praxis auch sagt, uns das Ganze wie einen Flug vorstellt.
Sprich, wir fangen an, nämlich zu Hause zu fliegen.
Fliegen ist eine Sache, die man vorbereiten muss.
Es ist meistens nicht gut, wenn man einfach direkt an den Startplatz geht, ohne jegliche Vorgeschichte gemacht zu haben.
Und dann überrascht ist, was einen antrifft.
Sprich, wenn man schon zu Hause überlegt, was man eigentlich heute machen will,
kann einem das viel, viel erleichtern.
Und dazu gehört schon die erste Sache, nämlich, ob man überhaupt fit ist, um zu fliegen.
Das heisst, weiss ich eigentlich, wie meine Verfassung ist?
Bin ich frei im Kopf?
Habe ich vorher nicht irgendwelche durchsächte Nächte gehabt und habe noch einen halben Kater?
Bin ich fit?
Habe ich nicht irgendwelche Medikamente genommen, die mich vielleicht, wenn ich irgendeinen Schmerz habe, dann schmerzlindern?
Das sind alles Sachen, die uns dann extrem beeinflussen können und vielleicht nicht schlau sind, um zu fliegen.
Und wichtig auch, dass wir Informationen vom Wetter holen, von den Sachen, die uns betreffen.
Hier gibt es eine ganz einfache Regel, die sogenannte FFG-Regel.
Das ist jetzt auf das Wetter bezogen.
Wenn wir uns diese merken, momentan in der Corona-Zeit,
fehlt das Wort FFP2-Maske.
Als Esselsbruck haben wir die FFG-Regel.
Und die FFG-Regel ist nichts anderes, als haben wir eine Gefahr zu erwarten,
die Föhn heisst.
Haben wir eine Gefahr zu erwarten,
die Front heisst.
Und haben wir eine Gefahr zu erwarten,
die Gewitter heisst.
Kommt eines dieser drei Themen im Wetterbericht vor,
müssen unsere Ohren ganz gross werden.
Und hören, was ist denn der Fall.
Weil, ihr kennt es, eine Front kommt auch fest im Meteo-Teil dieser Kurse,
bringt meistens sehr viel Wind mit sich.
Starker Wind ist immer eher schlecht für die Gleitschirmflügerei,
weil wir relativ langsam unterwegs sind.
Der Föhn ist allgemein eine gefährliche Situation.
Wo als Schüler nicht in die Luft gehörst.
Später, wenn man sehr erfahren ist,
gibt es geografische Gelände,
die auch bei Föhn durchaus den Flug erlauben können.
Aber da muss man sehr viel Vorwissen haben.
Und Gewitter, auch hier wieder sehr unberechenbar.
Da muss man viel Erfahrung haben.
Und Gewitter gilt jetzt allgemein lieber
frei und safe zu landen,
als irgendein Spiel herauszuholen,
das meistens nicht gut herauskommt.
Dann wichtig, dass man die Foren erkennt.
Auch bezüglich Gesetze.
Schliesslich gibt es eine Segelflugkarte,
die uns die Gesetzeslage beschreibt.
Und es gibt auch Luftraumbeschränkungen,
die relativ happig sein können, wenn man es nicht weiss.
Und um diese Luftraumbeschränkungen zu erfahren,
muss man von jedem Flugtag ins Tabs schauen,
ob eine aktuelle Luftraumbeschränkung vorhanden ist.
Das kann zum Teil etwas Grosses sein,
wie z.B. das World Economic Forum in Davos,
wo der Luftraum sehr grossweitig gesperrt ist.
Und ich könnte euch vorstellen,
auch dort, wenn man reinfliegen möchte,
relativ schnell eine Begleitung bekommt
von etwas grösseren Flugzeugen,
also ein Gleitschirm ist,
also nicht wahnsinnig schlau dort hineinfliegen.
Es gibt aber auch kleine Beschränkungen,
z.B. haben sie eine Abstimmung,
zapp in die Zelle,
der Landsplainsplatz ist voll mit Leuten,
da gibt es einen Zylinder oben drauf,
der auch dort verboten ist,
um darüber zu fliegen,
weil es einfach eine sehr grosse Menschenansammlung ist.
Diese Informationen findet ihr im Tab,
relativ gut beschrieben.
Und dann muss man natürlich auch beachten,
wo man hineinfliegen will,
z.B. bei einem Streckenflug,
und das sind militärische Flüge,
Militärflugdienstzeiten, wichtig,
dass man diese kennt,
weil je nachdem kann man nämlich dann höher hochfliegen,
als militär an ist,
also am Wochenende ist es etwas geringer,
als z.B. unter der Woche.
Was auch ganz dazugehört,
ist das Materialchecken,
dass man weiss,
dass das Material, das man dabei hat, funktioniert.
Da gehört z.B. auch das Aufladen der Batterie dazu.
Es nützt nichts, wenn man in eine Notsituation kommt
und das Handy einen leeren Akku hat,
dann kann man sich nicht mitteilen, wo man ist.
Und auch natürlich das Material allgemein,
der Zustand des Schirms,
dass der okay ist,
wenn man eine lange Flugpause hatte,
sich aber gewissen kann,
dass der Notschirm frisch gepackt ist.
Das sollte man mindestens jedes Jahr packen lassen.
Von jemandem, der das auch wirklich kann.
Und dann der Schirm selber weiss,
dass dieser Zustand, den man versorgt hat,
auch wieder so herauskommt.
Sprich, es wäre nicht schlau,
den Schirm zusammenzulegen,
der ist noch irgendwie vorher in Mist gelandet
und der Mist ist am Schirm
und der Schirm ist dann wochenlang im Kofferraum des Autos,
wo es warm ist.
Das sind alles Sachen,
die später in den Materialkurs kommen,
die nicht gut sind für den Schirm.
Und es kann natürlich auch sein,
dass dementsprechend nicht das dich erwartet,
was du denkst.
Auch wichtig ist,
die Bepflegung mitzunehmen,
dass man genug zu trinken dabei hat.
Trinken ist eigentlich am allerwichtigsten.
Das Essen ist meistens so,
dass man durch irgendwelche Energieriegel
relativ schnell die Energie auch bekommt.
Trinken wird oft vergessen
und auch bewusst zum Teil nicht gemacht,
weil es einen kleinen Nachteil hat,
wenn man viel trinkt.
Man muss auch aufs WC.
Aber auch dafür gibt es Lösungen,
wie zum Beispiel Urinalkondome,
wo man dann auch in der Luft prünzeln kann.
Und für die Frauen gibt es auch Windeln
und dieses Problem kann man in den Griff bekommen.
Aber es ist nicht schlau,
wegen diesem Problem aufs Trinken zu verzichten.
Trinken ist ganz wichtig,
damit wir aufnahmefähig bleiben,
in der Luft fit bleiben
und das am Ende des Flugtags
auch nicht gebiest wird durch den Kopfweh,
den wir nämlich hätten,
wenn wir zu wenig trinken.
Dann, wenn wir die ganzen Vorbereitungen
zu Hause gemacht haben,
macht es Sinn,
dass wir uns zuerst den Landeplatz anschauen.
Weil gerade beim Landeplatz
sind Gefahren offensichtlich,
weil man relativ wenig Höhe hat,
sich darauf zu begibt.
Und dann ist es gut,
wenn man diesen bereits kennt.
Das heisst eine saubere Landeplatzbesichtigung
macht durchaus Sinn.
Wir schauen bereits,
wo es eventuelle Hindernisse hat,
wie zum Beispiel Kabel,
die in der Nähe sind,
über das Tal gehen.
Wo zum Beispiel ein grosser Baum ist,
den man vielleicht beachten muss,
wenn man bei der Lande wollte.
Und wie überhaupt die Lande wollte,
ist auf diesem Gelände.
Dafür gibt es gute Hilfsmittel,
nämlich wie meist die lokalen Piloten,
die wissen, wie die Lande wollte,
geregelt ist in ihrem Gebiet.
Standard wollte ist eine links wollte.
Das kann aber je nach Begebenheit
des Landeplatzes auch variieren
und eben eine rechts wollte sein,
je nach Windverhältnis.
Das ist meistens gut angeschrieben
am Landeplatz auf einer Tafel sichtbar.
Wenn nicht, fragen die Locals.
Dann auch wichtig,
dass wir wissen,
wo wir überhaupt durchfliegen.
Wir machen ein bisschen Flugplanung.
Sprich, wenn wir am Landeplatz stehen,
können wir schon einmal schauen,
wo der Startplatz ist.
Meistens sieht man,
wo eventuell auch ein Notlandeplatz ist.
Wenn jetzt ein Landeplatz gesperrt wäre,
kann ja sein,
dass irgendetwas passiert ist.
Sie müssen einen Wanderer auflesen,
der sich das Bein gebrochen hat.
Der Rega-Helikopter landet genau auf dem Landeplatz.
Es ist wichtig,
dass wir dann wissen,
wo wir dann landen.
Und es gibt irgendwelche Sachen,
die wir überlegen müssen
bezüglich Turbulenzen.
Es gibt Häuser,
grosse Bäume,
die Turbulenzen machen könnten.
Ein bisschen Talwind,
der uns beim Landen stören könnte.
All diese Überlegungen vorgängig zu machen,
erleichtert einen den Flug allgemein sehr stark,
weil man dann einen Plan B im Kopf hat.
Und der Plan B ist etwas sehr Wichtiges.
Wir sollten nie noch hinfliegen,
wenn wir nicht wissen,
was machen wir,
wenn es mal nicht so läuft,
wie wir gedacht haben.
Immer vorgängig überlegen,
was ist wann.
Dazu gehört auch die Überlegung,
zu machen bezüglich Wild.
Wir haben den Wildschutz als grosses Thema.
Früher war das immer so in zweitrangig.
Da hat man gesagt,
die Gleitschirmflügel
erschrecken das Wild kaum.
Die neue Studie,
die gerade herausgekommen ist,
zeigt eher das Gegenteil,
dass der Gleitschirmpilot
doch ein bisschen Verantwortung
gegenüber dem Wild hat.
Und auch ganz wichtig ist,
das zu beachten.
Wir haben einerseits
die lokalen Wildabmachungen,
die sind auch auf dieser Infotafel
meistens bei der Bahn beschrieben,
wo z.B. Zonen sind,
in die man gar nicht fliegen sollte.
Aber es ist auch wichtig,
ein bisschen Bescheid zu wissen
über das ganze Wild.
Und in den Theoriefragen,
die wir kennen für dieses Thema,
sind auch ganz viele Fragen
bezüglich Wildschutz.
Hier geht es z.B. darum,
wann unsere Tiere in der Alpe
Junge haben,
weil genau in dieser Zeit
ist nämlich Frühling.
Und im Frühling
fliegen wir ja wunderschön hoch.
Das heisst,
wir kommen auch zu diesen Plätzen,
wo z.B. die Adler,
die Gämsen und die Steingeissen
ihre Jungen aufziehen.
Bei den Adlern muss man wirklich
im März bis Mai damit rechnen,
dass die auf dem Horst sitzen
und auch ihr Territorium verteidigen.
Bei den Gämsen ist es im Mai
und bei den Steingeissen ist es im Juni.
Und in dieser Zeit,
wenn ihr Tiere seht,
fliegen sie weg.
Es ist einfach fair gegenüber dem Tier,
dass man sich nicht irgendetwas sagt,
jetzt ist die Thermik da
besonders gut,
es ist mir egal,
wenn unter der Reihe Gämsen ist,
sondern fliegen sie weg.
Die Tiere haben sonst schon genug Stress
mit jeglicher Umweltbelastung,
damit wir als Gleitschimpiloten,
die so nahe der Natur sind,
nicht noch zusätzlich Stress verursachen.
Wie schon gesagt,
die lokalen Begebenheiten
von einzelnen Wildschutzgebieten
sind meistens gut lesbar
in den Stationen aufgelegt.
Und sonst auch hier nicht scheu sein,
sondern lokale Leute fragen.
Es geben alle immer gerne Auskunft.
Wenn wir auf den Berg kommen,
Richtung Startplatz,
ist es vielleicht für viele so,
dass sie bereits eine kleine Nervosität spüren.
Die Nervosität ist aber schlussendlich
eine gute Sache,
weil man die Sachen gut anschaut.
Und besonders,
wenn ihr einen Startplatz nicht kennt,
z.B. ein Hike & Fly macht,
auf ein Terrain kommt,
das ihr überhaupt nicht kennt,
ist es umso wichtiger,
dass hier der Leitsatz,
der hier steht,
beachtet wird.
Das ist nämlich
an und zu von jedem Startplatz
ein Muss,
jederzeit gefahrlos möglich sein,
den Start abzubrechen.
Wenn wir auf einer Klippe starten,
wo wir nur wenige Laufstrecke haben,
danach geht das endgerechte Loch ab,
dann wird das Zimmer sicher nicht der Fall sein
und dann ist das auch nicht
der richtige Startplatz.
Natürlich, je nach Können des Piloten
verschiebt sich diese Grenze ein wenig.
Aber dieser Leitsatz gilt für alle
und immer.
Danach haben wir natürlich
unterschiedliche Kriterien
des Startplatzes.
Sprich, wenn wir ankommen,
müssen wir zuerst wissen,
was wir für einen Wind haben.
Wenn wir natürlich Abwind haben,
sprich Rückenwind am Startplatz,
dann müssen wir definitiv einen Startplatz wählen,
wo wir sehr lange laufen können.
Sprich, der hindernisfrei ist.
Wir können nicht zwischen Steinen rennen,
sondern wir müssen schauen,
dass dieser Teil hindernisfrei ist,
den wir beschleunigen können
und auch dann beim Abheben
noch Geschwindigkeit machen müssen,
damit er möglichst hindernisfrei und gut ist.
Wenn wir den Startplatz antreffen,
es hat einen 20er Aufwind,
dann sieht die Sache natürlich etwas anders aus.
Dann können wir uns wunderschön
gegen den Schirm eindrehen
und einen Rückwärtsstart machen.
Dann kann es sein,
dass wir zuerst noch,
damit der Schirm nicht zu fest überschiesst,
dem Schirm entgegenlaufen müssen,
den Hang aufwärts.
Das heisst,
dann müssen wir schauen,
dass wir nicht hinter uns,
sondern eigentlich zum Schirm hin,
keine Hindernisse haben,
dass wir nicht stolpern.
Das Gleiche ist beim Seitenwind.
Wenn wir dort ein wenig Seitenwind haben,
dann müssen wir vielleicht
den Schirm gegen den Wind aufziehen
und dann ein kleines Stück
in die Fallrichtung laufen.
Dann muss dort
möglichst kein Hindernis sein.
Und das ist ein wichtiges Kriterium
für den Startplatz.
Das gehört auch dazu
zum Massenansammeln.
Gerade an öffentlichen Startplätzen,
die jetzt auf der Bahn hochgehen,
hat es sehr schnell sehr viele Zuschauer.
Diese Zuschauer sind einerseits nett,
dass sie unseren Sport auch zuschauen,
andererseits birgt es aber auch eine Gefahr.
Sprich, sie wollen vielleicht mit euch reden,
sie wollen Fragen beantwortet haben
und das Ganze lenkt euch ab.
Also macht es vielleicht auch Sinn,
einen Startplatz zu wählen,
wo ihr ein wenig Ruhe habt.
Gerade wenn ihr ein wenig
unsicher seid,
ihr müsst euch noch ein wenig verinnerlichen
vom ganzen Startprozess.
Nehmt euch Zeit,
arbeitet ruhig,
nie hektisch
und dann gibt es auch einen sauberen Start.
Wenn ihr dann bereit seid,
den Start anzugehen,
ist eines unablässlich,
nämlich, dass ihr einen sauberen Check macht.
Und den Check,
das habt ihr,
wenn ihr schon im Übungsangst gewesen seid,
sicher schon dort gelernt,
ist auch in der Theorie ein ganz grosses Thema
und das sollte man
immer gewissenhaft machen.
Anfangen tut das Ganze eigentlich dann,
wenn das Gurtzeug am Boden liegt
und du es aufnimmst und anziehst,
weil bereits dann und nur dann
kannst du es sauber kontrollieren,
ist dein Notschirmgriff sauber im Gurtzug drin.
Sind also die zwei Splinten,
aber die meisten sind es zwei,
es gibt auch Gurtzüge, die nur einen haben,
ist der Splint wirklich auch noch so drin,
wie es ist,
ist der Griff sauber dran,
sieht dort nicht irgendetwas aus,
ob etwas nicht passt
und das kannst du machen,
wenn du das Gurtzeug aufnimmst,
schaust zuerst den Notschirm an
und dann legst du es an.
Und dann für den 5-Punkte-Check
ist es am einfachsten,
beim Körper anzufangen.
Wir gehen von innen nach draussen.
Nämlich,
der Notschirm bereits kontrolliert,
gehen wir dann weiter
zu allen unseren Schnallen.
Sind die geschlossen und gesichert?
Da gehören wegen mir die Schuhbänder dabei,
da gehören wegen mir
auch die Helmschleusen dazu.
Wichtig ist einfach,
dass alle Schnallen
gesichert und gesichert sind.
Punkt 1.
Punkt 2.
Gehen wir dann weiter
von uns nach draussen,
nämlich zu der Traggurte.
Sind die nicht vertreibt?
Und laufen unsere Leinen,
die zum Schirm gehen,
wunschgemäss?
Also sprich,
haben wir die so sortiert,
ist dort kein Knopf drin,
liegen sie so,
wie wir das auch wollen?
Und dann kommen wir zu Punkt 3.
Liegt der Schirm wunschgemäss?
Also auch so,
wie wir es wollen?
Ist er schön offen
und schön im Wind ausgerichtet?
Und Punkt 4.
Gehen wir dann zur Windrichtung
und wichtig als Stärke.
Es nützt nichts,
wenn wir die Windrichtung richtig haben,
aber einen 50er Hangaufwind haben
oder einen 20er Rückenwind.
Dann ist die Stärke sicher nicht die richtige.
Und dann Punkt 5.
Ist die Startbahn und Luftraum frei?
Dafür immer noch mal schnell raufschauen.
Jawohl,
es sind keine vorbeifliegenden
anderen Piloten rum.
Und auch die Startbahn
ist wirklich frei.
Hat es nicht irgendwelche Kinder
oder Tiere rum,
die plötzlich könnten
noch während des Startprozeders
in eure Startbahn hineinlaufen?
Wenn das der Fall ist,
dann wartet lieber,
schickt die Kinder weg,
wartet,
wenn die Kuh noch etwas grasen will
und startet erst dann.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
wenn ihr mit eurer Masse,
sagen wir mal,
ich bin 80 Kilo
mit dem Gleitschirm und allem drum und dran,
bin ich schnell mal 100 Kilo
und ich beschleunige auf 20 kmh,
dann ist das eine kinetische Energie,
die für denjenigen,
den ich treffen würde,
sehr schnell richtig gefährlich werden kann.
Wenn wir einen Rückwärtsstart machen,
wir haben also einen guten Wind,
wir können tiptop Rückwärtsstart machen,
dann drehen wir uns nach einem 5-Punkte-Check um
zum Schirm.
Jetzt von Punkt 1 bis 4
ändert sich nicht mehr viel,
aber was sich wieder ändern kann,
ist nämlich,
dass die Startbahn,
zum Beispiel der Luftraum,
nicht mehr frei ist.
Darum unmittelbar vor dem Rückwärtsstart
Punkt 5 nochmals sauber wiederholen.
Danach gehen wir langsam ans Starten
und ihr habt recht schon gehört,
das heisst der sogenannte 3-Phase-Start.
Und zwar fangen wir an mit der Aufziehphase,
danach kommt die Kontrolle
und die Korrekturphase
und dann kommt die Beschleunigungsphase.
Und dort ist es ganz wichtig,
dass wir das auch in diesen 3 Schritten überlegen.
Viele Piloten gehen am Startplatz
schon viel zu weit mit dem Kopf,
die sind schon in der Luft
oder schon am Beschleunigen.
Statt einfach zu sagen,
zuerst mache ich jetzt mal Punkt 1 und Punkt 2 sauber,
nämlich aufziehen,
Kontrolle und Korrektur
und dann entscheide ich mich,
passt alles so wie ich will,
fühle mich sicher,
fühlt es sich gut an,
dann gehe ich in die Beschleunigungsphase.
Und mache nicht alle 3 gleichzeitig,
weil die Kontrolle und Korrekturphase
ist ja genau dafür da,
damit wir einen Fehler erkennen.
Der Schirm ist zum Beispiel schräg,
wir haben einen Knopf in der Leine,
wir haben irgendetwas, das uns nicht passt,
wir brechen ab.
Wenn wir uns in der Beschleunigungsphase
schon befinden,
das hat keinen Abbruch mehr zu erfolgen,
weil wie das Wort sagt,
Beschleunigung,
wir sind schnell unterwegs
und diesen Bereich wollen wir
eigentlich möglichst schnell verlassen,
nämlich in die Luft,
weil in die Luft sind wir wieder safe.
Da haben wir keine Hindernisse mehr bekommen,
wir könnten nicht mehr stolpern,
in der Luft ist alles wieder gut.
Wichtig ist,
1 und 2 sauber machen
und dann entscheiden,
jawohl passt Beschleunigen
oder nein passt nicht,
abbrechen.
Übrigens auch an einer Praxisprüfung,
solange ihr in Punkt 1 oder Punkt 2 abbrecht,
ist das ein sauberer Abbruch
und kein Problem.
Wenn ihr Punkt 3 der Beschleunigungsphase abbrecht,
dann habt ihr nämlich Punkt 2 nicht sauber gemacht
und dann kann es einen Negativpunkt geben in der Prüfung.
Wichtig ist nachher,
wenn wir in die Abhebbeschwindigkeit kommen,
dass wir auch abheben
und ganz wichtig,
dass man nach dem Start unsere Bremse nicht loslässt.
Wir sehen immer wieder in der Praxis,
dass die Leute rausfliegen
und sich relativ schnell bequem machen wollen im Gurtzug.
Das ist ja gut und nett fürs Bequemen,
aber es birgt Gefahr in sich,
dass man nämlich die Bremse loslässt.
Und jetzt hast du irgendeine Störung,
die du vielleicht gar nicht bemerkt hast beim Starten
oder ein bisschen viel Seitenwind
und der Schirm zieht relativ schnell auf eine Seite.
Und das ist schlicht und einfach mit Gefahren verbunden
und darum setzt euch erst dann ins Gurtzug rein,
macht euch erst dann bequem,
wenn ihr weit, weit gerade in die Flugrichtung,
die gewünscht ist, fliegt,
viel Luft unter euch habt,
dann kann man die Bremse schnell loslassen
und sich bequem machen
und dann die Bremse dazu wieder nehmen.
Jetzt gibt es ja auch die Situation,
dass man unmittelbar nach dem Start
merkt, dass wir eben nicht geradeaus fliegen,
sondern nach rechts oder nach links.
Das kann verschiedene Ursachen haben.
Das kann zum Beispiel sein,
dass wir schon grundsätzlich beim Start
nicht sauber in die Fallrichtung sind,
sondern etwas schräg gestartet sind.
Das kann sein, dass wir einen Knopf,
den wir nicht gesehen haben,
in der Leine haben.
Oder es kann auch sein,
dass wir einen starken Seitenwind haben,
der uns ein bisschen drückt gegen die eine Seite.
Allerallerwichtigstes,
und das sollte eigentlich im 3-Phase-Start
der vierte Punkt sein.
Und der vierte Punkt ist eigentlich
die richtige Stabilisierung in die,
die wir wollen.
Nämlich gerade weg vom Gelände.
Und das muss absolute Priorität sein,
egal was der Grund ist,
dass wir auf eine Seite gehen.
Zuerst sauber Gewicht verlagern,
effizient mit der Gegenbremse so fest steuern,
dass wir geradeaus fliegen,
weit, weit raus,
wieder viel Distanz zwischen uns
und dem Boden machen
und dann sich um das Problem kümmern.
Wenn wir das nicht machen,
die Gefahren dabei sind glaube ich
ziemlich offensichtlich.
Nämlich, dass wir unkontrolliert
wieder Richtung Hand gehen.
Und es ist je nach Gelände
natürlich nicht schlau,
dort hinein zu landen.
Eine Landung würde ich nicht bevorzugen.
Ich würde immer in offenen Luftraum hineinfliegen,
weil dann verschaffe ich mir Zeit,
um zu reagieren.
Und hier ist es wieder gut,
je grösser mein Zeitfenster ist,
desto ruhiger kann ich das Problem angehen
und dementsprechend reagieren.
Wichtig ist, wenn wir ein Problem haben,
wir nehmen jetzt einmal die Hand,
doch einen Knopf in der Leine,
obwohl wir unseren Check sauber gemacht haben.
Und wir haben sogar den 3-Phase-Start,
Punkt 2 sauber gemacht,
nämlich Kontrolle und Korrektur,
und haben doch blöderweise
einen Knopf in der Leine,
den wir nicht gesehen haben
und fliegen jetzt draussen.
Wichtig ist, stabilisieren,
geradeaus fliegen,
wie schon besprochen.
Und apropos Knöpfe,
in der ganzen Flugkarriere
kein Pilot gibt es wahrscheinlich,
der sagt, er hätte noch nie einen Knopf gemacht.
Oder respektive hatte.
Es ist etwas,
wo man einfach durch das hat,
dass wir halt lose Leinen haben
und meistens in glänzenden Arten,
wo man vielleicht Steinchen hat
oder hohes Gras,
wo sich mal ein Knopf bilden kann.
Das ist nicht tragisch,
solange man weiss,
wie damit umzugehen.
Wichtig ist,
wenn wir das haben,
rausfliegen,
freien Luftraum,
jetzt kümmere ich mich um das Problem
und jetzt schaue ich zuerst einmal,
was das Problem ist.
Erkenne ich,
aha,
habe ich jetzt tatsächlich einen Knopf.
Wenn ich diesen Knopf habe,
dann kann ich entscheiden,
bringe ich diesen Knopf auf.
Da gibt es verschiedene Hilfsmittel,
um den Knopf zu öffnen.
Das kann zum Beispiel sein,
dass ich mit der Bremse
auf der Knopfseite einen Impuls gebe.
Das kann sein,
dass der Knopf wieder aufgeht.
Es kann sein,
dass ich die Stabilo-Leine,
das ist die äusserste Farbe,
meistens die Trend-Leine,
die zum Stabilo geht,
dass ich diese runterziehe.
Oder ich habe auch einen Knopf,
der zum Beispiel vorne ist,
mit einem Klapper,
50% Klapper,
wo wir später noch dazukommen,
wie man das macht,
kann ich den Schirm so entlasten,
dass die Chance gross ist,
dass der Knopf wieder aufgeht.
Wenn der Knopf aufgeht,
ist es ja super,
dann fliegen wir weiter,
geniessen diesen Flug,
wenn der Knopf nicht aufgeht.
Und wir können den Zustand
von geradeaus fliegen
gleich einmal so halten,
indem wir fest Gewicht hinlegen,
ein wenig Gegenbremse geben
und geradeaus fliegen.
Dann müssen wir uns entscheiden,
können wir so landen?
Und wenn wir uns diese Frage
mit 100 %
beantworten können,
dann machen wir es.
Dann gehen wir so landen.
Wenn wir aber unsicher sind
und sagen,
fliegen, geradeaus,
ist ja gleich noch so weiss,
aber jetzt beim Landen
sollte ich noch Kurven machen
und noch gegen den Wind
und ich weiss nicht mal,
wo der Landeplatz ist,
dann wird man schnell
in die Überforderung kommen.
Dann macht es absolut Sinn,
solange wir noch steuern können,
über ein grosses Feld,
möglichst nicht über den Wald,
über eine grosse Wiese zu fliegen
und dann den Notschirm zu geben.
Notschirmsituationen
kommen wir später noch dazu,
aber dass ihr das schon mal gehört habt.
Die Hundskurve.
Die Hundskurve ist eigentlich das,
was wir vermeiden wollen,
weil es uns schlussendlich
den Flugweg kostet
und die Zeit,
also sprich,
wir kommen weniger hoch an
an dem Punkt,
an dem wir wollen.
Wenn wir jetzt einen Punkt anpeilen
und wir haben null Wind,
dann kommen wir einfach darauf zu
und kommen genauso schön hoch an,
wie wir wollen.
Wenn wir jetzt aber
Seitenwindkomponenten haben,
in diesem Fall von links,
und wir würden einfach
auf den Punkt zufliegen,
dann gibt es eine sogenannte
Hundskurve
und wir machen,
übertrieben gesagt,
einen grossen Umweg
und kommen dann deutlich
tiefer an den Punkt,
als wir vielleicht wollen.
Darum müssen wir
einen Vorhalterwinkel wählen.
Der Vorhalterwinkel ist nichts anderes,
als der Winkel zwischen
der Längsachse des Geräts
und dem Flugweg,
den wir wählen.
Und wenn wir diesen
ein bisschen gegen den Wind wählen,
dann machen wir eine schöne,
gerade Linie
Richtung Punkt
und kommen so optimal
dort an,
wo wir wollen.